hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes last game we had
the black pieces and I blundered a pawn
in the opening but I was able to turn it
around first my opponent gave me back
the pawn and then uh somehow uh even
another one that allowed me to win the
game in a in a pretty fine fashion so
we'll see what happens in next one uh
let's start the game uh again 10 minutes
per player 0 seconds increment and I
will do my best to explain my uh thought
process um while I'm doing it so uh
let's who our opponent is for this
session uh let me just fix the sound a
little bit there we
go
uh we'll see what we get all right so we
get the black pieces and our opponent is
uh ne ne neosite and starting with G3 so
it's a uh pretty pretty fine way to
start uh I'm going to reply with C5 I
thought about going for just the
standard G6 Knight F6 Bishop G7 and
castles but um yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm
thinking of going uh yeah let's play the
hyper accelerated dragon against C4 so
it's a C4 G3 Bishop G2 Knight F3 and uh
let's see what we can get from it he
starts with H5 right away we're going to
stop further expansion with H5 because I
don't want to see H5 on the board
anytime soon and okay the Knight getting
developed now I have weakened G5 so
Knight to G5 itely is an option but uh
yeah okay uh he can play that we're
going to
Castle uh we're going to okay the Knight
comes
to the Knight comes to F4 very early on
which is okay now
I'm kind of puzzled here how to go about
this he does have very nice control over
the D5
Square uh but he also weakened his light
squares a little bit
here
so let's just bring the Knight into the
game and we'll decide where to put our
pawns later
on
huh very
interesting very
interesting yeah let's do it like this
D6 let's free up our light Square bishop
and we might even uh play Knight to D4
simply to to ask what what he what he
plans to do with the Knight on
F4 yeah let's do that right away best as
best best is to ask the question right
away okay so let's ask him what do you
do with what do you do with the knight
uh we are giving up the B Pawn but
uh no he doesn't want the the B Pawn I
actually wanted to give up The Rook for
my for his light Square bishop and play
an U well sort of an active game but
yeah okay he wants to
trade uh let's trade he cannot take with
the Knight because the bishop would hang
so he's going to take with the pawn and
he has a double D Pawn now which uh yeah
okay maybe you can play
it you will probably Advance E4 at some
point no not right away of course and
now we're going to challenge the the
center with with E6 right away do we do
it right away or do we REM maneuver the
Knight back to F6 to control some fine
squares
here yeah let's REM maneuver the Knight
I don't need to rush anything okay so
what what is the Knight doing there he
wants to trade off the dark Square
Bishops uh sure sure let's do
it yeah I'd love to play B5 here but
then he can just play A4 as my Rook
still isn't
connected so let's bring the Knight into
the
game and okay he wants to get rid of his
doubled Pawn which is uh fine I'm going
to play B6
here maybe some other moves uh were also
to be considered but I don't think
there's a problem with
uh uh with this let's get the bishop to
A6 put pressure on his
Knight yeah and he wants to capture with
the with the Rook if I take so we're
going to play Rook to B1 always useful
to get the Rook off of this diagonal and
queen here okay so he wants some
infiltrating action with the queen uh
we're going to prevent
that
H yeah I'm going to play kn Knight G4
here I want to play Knight G4 simply be
annoying and then if he plays F3 I can
always capture here and then REM
maneuver my knight here so that's one
way to do
it yeah let's go for
that he's going to move the Rook of
course he doesn't want to see Knight
here
uh but we can just take we can just
take and now go here and if he ever
wants to kick away my knight with F4
because that's the only move that he has
to kick away the knight uh then we
really weaken the E3 Pawn okay so this
is nice he can even move the queen into
the game uh to sort of
uh put pressure yeah okay Queen A5 gets
to trade Queens but I don't think it's a
problem
uh my my a pawn is a little bit
weak but I don't see him actually
doubling up Rooks on the a file or
anything so yeah okay so he stops uh any
any C4 action anytime
soon uh we can just uh we can just how
do we go about
this what's a good way what's a good way
to deal with
this go Rook B6 simply double our Rooks
and if he goes here it's not a problem
we'll just play
A6 he wants to play B4 yeah know he he
goes after the pawn and uh yeah we'll
play A6 now the
problem looks a little bit weird maybe
but not too
weird yeah okay so he goes back now he
he's kind of saying okay I have some
pressure I might be able to play B4 here
so uh how do we how do we make his idea
not that
useful yeah let's move the queen let's
move the queen sort of in front of his
Bishop but I don't see the position
opening up anytime soon so we have uh
our defense set up we've stopped B4 we
can triple up on the B file and and uh
yeah it's okay nothing spectacular but I
like my position since I didn't create
any long-term weaknesses and the Knight
on E5 no he actually goes for F4
okay okay we'll put a knight on
G4 yeah he goes after it which is
fine uh which is fine we're going to
defend
it and now if I double my Rooks on the B
file again I'm thinking I'm thinking
we're okay here now he can actually grab
more space yeah okay so he really wants
to get B4 in or maybe even start with
something like A4 or A3
B4 yeah not not a lot to worry about
here
hopefully but he might have some ideas
okay so he goes in with the
King and
uh yeah what's a good way to do it let's
just bring the Rook to B4 let's uh let's
be
annoying it's much better on time but he
does control more space so it's nothing
uh nothing weird there let's go
A5 if he goes E5 yeah he can do
that
uh but we're we're probably just going
to ignore it yeah no he he he he takes
here yeah which is very nice and we're
going to capture with the
queen yeah okay so he does push uh means
that pushing will sort of open up and
attack
here uh so we will what will we do yeah
let's let's just go after that
pawn I think that's the way to do
it E6 although looks annoying doesn't
really do all that much I I believe as
long as he's not having any active
pressure on my G6 opponent with my queen
on
G4 yeah it doesn't look uh doesn't look
spectacular so I'm just trying to weaken
his position if I can open up the B file
or the a file while I can maybe put some
pressure on his king and queen because
although his position maybe is
solid uh he will have to trade
down and once I get uh one Rook off the
board
then yeah I do have a safer King yeah
okay so he does trade uh we're going to
capture with the Rook of course he might
bring the other Rook to C4 yeah that's
one way to do
it that's definitely one way to do
it but I think we're just uh faster
here we're just faster
here yeah okay I'm going to take back
but now if he takes with the queen he
gives up this Square oh no he he will
capture here first
so yeah let's take this Pawn First
okay and he also wants to get a queen
into the game problem is his Queen comes
with Tempo so we're going to play this
he has to tend to the pawn and then
we'll take this Pawn no we're not going
to take it oh yeah I missed that yeah I
thought he captures I take with check no
it's not happening but still still we're
better we're defending this Pawn Yeah
it's a queen and pawn end game not uh
not a lot we do have sort of the
outsides past pawn and he has the
Central Pawn
PA yeah of course he he wants to set up
uh some Pawn pushing
action uh and I don't think we can even
do all that much damage here like
probably it's best to just
blockade as I don't think we're faster
here or
anything I don't think we're faster
here yeah we're going to block it once
we're going to block it once before we
start uh advancing since he's not going
to be able to attack it yeah okay so he
stops uh he stops the expansion here and
we don't have much
yeah we don't have much we can allow
some checks uh because they don't really
do
anything yeah that's
nice so we're just going to go
here yeah we're going to go here just
because if he plays this I can trade and
the uh I I can reach the pawn and
without that uh it's not all that much
yeah let's even go
here yeah it's very interesting stuff
here
huh yeah let's go
back let's go back not a lot to do
here yeah okay you can play
that you can play
that but what's next what is next that
is the
question
yeah okay we were kind of thinking
that's the that's the way to go now
Queen E5 does control
this yeah he might be outplaying me a
little bit here and he's much better on
time that's for sure but no he just
blundered his Queen so it's fine yeah he
he over pushed and he really wanted to
win and that resulted in the loss uh but
otherwise I think it's a drop
yeah it's a shame
to to suffer this but I was lower on
time and probably he thought that he was
going to be able to push it uh but yeah
that's you as usual let's go uh check
out what just happened here so he
started with G3 uh I mean there are many
choices you can make here like probably
usually I just go for the standard setup
like Knight F6 G6 Bishop G7 castles D6
E5 something you would play Maybe
against the king's Indian uh but uh as
I'm not really
uh sure on this uh I decided to go for
uh some sort some sort of an accelerated
uh dragon type hyper accelerated dragon
type structure against this uh setup
here uh okay so he put a knight on F4 I
when Knight C6 G3 I play D6 yeah okay
Knight Knight into the center perfectly
fine yeah this is still
0 uh I went back I tried to trade a
knight we traded here I play KN back to
C D7 yeah even B5 right away yeah maybe
that's the way to go but still okay this
is perfectly fine yeah some maneuvering
here play Knight F6 B6 okay captures
captures Knight C4 I played Bishop to A6
we're actually playing decent moves here
yeah these are all pretty much top moves
I went with Knight to G4 yeah okay
Knight D5 I was very happy to get my
knight to F5 because like I said you
cannot oppose it and if you ever play F4
you have have to weaken your position a
little bit but yeah still it's it's an
equal game yeah this is nothing A6 Queen
D2 Queen B7 I got the Knight to G4 he
attacked it and uh okay Rook B4
obviously right away I decided to go for
this first because I didn't want to
allow the capture I wanted to capture
back with the queen uh probably it's
okay to allow Pawn captures because
later on I can play F5 but I thought
this would blockade my position as well
and I thought maybe if uh like a knight
for uh a Bishop for Knight trade occurs
and I managed to get the Rooks of the
board that I will have a slightly better
Queen end game but okay he went for this
I doubled up here Rook B4 yeah okay five
it's uh seems to be a decent plan yeah I
played A4 yeah pretty much playing only
moves here it's not bad yeah and now
okay so
here says my position is winning but not
the move I played but Rook captures here
for what reason captures captures and
queen E4 check
yeah okay King moves and I get another
Pawn okay so it would be a better Queen
end game being up a pawn okay I missed
that I I actually thought this was
winning as well uh but I missed that
after all of the captures here that um I
thought if he captures here I can
capture this with check but he captured
I played Queen captures here and now
it's a dead
draw uh it's a dead draw yeah probably
at some point he maybe even got a little
bit something no I'm winning here Queen
B6 winning for
me uh simply because he has to blockade
the pawn and then F5 okay King goes back
and then I block it the pawn yeah ah was
not very precise there uh King E5 yeah I
went here yeah now again it's a draw but
he delivered a check and yeah here he
just blundered so yeah not the not the
most precise game but I was okay uh
throughout the entire game he gave me he
gave me some winning posss and uh it
seems that out of the three winning
moves that he gave me I only took
advantage of the one that was fairly
obvious um but yeah other than that uh
not uh not a lot of mistakes and uh
that's pretty much what these videos are
for I'm not uh excellent at openings
probably you guys already figured that
out I don't know openings I just play
you know what uh feels natural and uh
yeah if sometimes my opponent misses a
tactic I might find it but most I'm just
trying to be principled and to give you
an idea of maybe what I think about
basically trying to actively uh explain
my thought process while playing the
game so here I did took a little bit
more time and I was already down on the
clock um but yeah you know it's it's a
drawish position maybe if my opponent
played it perfectly I would lose on time
uh but uh he over pushed it yeah and uh
it's sort of a last minute blunder uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're currently at 2278 so
getting near that 2300 we'll see uh
we'll see how long we can keep doing
this without actually uh starting to
feel the pressure of our lack of theory
knowledge in the opening uh so yeah once
again hope you enjoy that as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and uh everything
else that happens in the Chess World uh
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day